hi I'm Nicolas be with reason thanks for
coming everybody and I hope everybody
enjoyed the movie this afternoon if it
was your first time seeing it or a
couple people it was their fourth or
fifth congratulations what we're getting
what we're going to do tonight is we've
got two producers or three producers one
visionary of one actor we're going to
talk real quickly how I'm going to throw
a question at each of you and then we're
going to open it up because I know that
everybody here has tons of questions and
we'll try and get through stuff as
quickly as possible I'm going to start
with John Aguilera the person who owned
the rights who put everything in motion
John when did can you set the scene for
us and was it a randiyan moment when you
said you've read this book you
envisioned a movie and then you would
said okay this is if we're going forward
period well the rights were coming to an
end and I always thought it was going to
be someone else's issue someone else's
problem someone else's challenge
and then when I realized that I there
was a moment was that we have a beach
house in Avalon New Jersey and I'm just
walking in the beach and I said this
book this movie where Iran would have
wanted it's a it's a liberation of the
human spirit and then it's even more
touching that you probably said that as
medical waste was washing up on your
feet but you have to get I don't know
but but it was sunset yeah in the light
I like yeah obviously the East Coast it
was already a car guy now in age but now
well and you had the rights for how long
since this longest in 1992 yeah so this
is well congratulations I mean you made
it happen and we're going to carbon
harmon kaslo you know I think somebody
like John Huston had it easier because
he only was trying to film the Bible how
do you you know what what is your you
know how did how do you approach a book
you know and obviously it's already
split into three parts and you know and
that's just the first part of John gulps
radio address so you know we're looking
at the prequel here but how I mean how
do you go about condensing this material
even even know you're going to be making
a series of movements well well first
off that responsibility didn't really
fall on my shoulders but what was
important for John and me at the outset
was really you know how to manage our
ambition within all of the constraints
that we had which was really you know a
trying to do it for the right amount of
money and we had this ticking clock that
we had to observe or would all be for
naught and so it was really about
finding somebody who could collaborate
with John and coming up with
some sort of cinematic thread through
the book it became apparent very early
on that there was no way we had the time
to be able to consider a fool adaptation
of the book so originally we were just
talking about just getting to you know
the bridge sequence and you know as as
things started to unfold and I think as
John saw this all coming together you
know he said okay you know let's take it
all the way through the end of part one
which you know I didn't make me feel any
better because that was now it was I
think was like 70 pages but so much
happen I mean to me as I going great we
just got to get to the bridge will find
somebody who can do the bridge and then
we're done and yeah we'll go have a
great summer but then John was like no
no no no no I've got I've got to go all
the way through and and that was very
challenging for us but it was really a
very collaborative effort and as we ran
into issues about how we were going to
execute things the things you know jon
was always you know let's go look and
see how it's done in the book and try to
be its faithful to the book because we
could you know that's a good point that
add on to that it was and I have not
thought about it till just ask that
question we thought remember that the
ending that would be after the love
scene perfect time to end it they go
over the bridge there they have dinner
they have the love scene and in part one
but it would have been too short a film
it would not have had that impact why
were people leaving what was happening
societies had
and then where I n'rae intended it when
elephant I one strike and that was about
34 million dollars more literally
attended center it's because we were
trying to you know making a movie is
really it's a function of time and so
that's just me just a function of time
well each day has a cost to it and so by
John's right i mean it literally was
like how many more days would it take
for us to to finish this and you looked
at indigo everything else is pretty
content for the most part except when
you start driving around to Louisiana
Wisconsin and Wyoming and so yeah it's a
real credit to the production team to be
able to fit all of that in and only add
a couple more million dollars of course
john collins mike Marvin you know I know
you were talking at the dinner table
before amount about Iwo Jima we were
talking about the Academy yeah we were
having very light conversation dinner
time
we're laughing uproariously we're sorry
if we disturbed your conversation but
you know Rotten Tomatoes I looked before
I came out here rotten tomatoes the
movie review aggregator site they said
five percent of critics liked the movie
eighty-five percent of the audience did
can you put that in a context that also
encompasses the the yield so far or the
early indicators of this screen / the
average take per screen of the of the
movie you mean in context of yeah well
we've done yeah tell us tell us how the
film is doing on a per screen basis the
film is number one in the country the
director of the movie Paul Johansson's
wife is having a baby I think tonight or
the next couple of days but he sent me a
an email and the email showed I think
it's rio and a couple of other movies
and he put a lol and it was that you
know Atlas Shrugged for yesterday Friday
was the number one movie in the United
States on a period does it seem
that's a it's amazing and does it seem
it somehow in keeping that the critical
reception might be mixed but the
audience response is huge because this
seems like totally in keeping with rants
reception which is that there's
something about her work that an
audience gets that escapes the
gatekeepers and the Wesley mouches of
Harry Reid and I yeah the Harry Reid to
go let's keep I shouldn't have said it
let's keep a reasoned approach right to
this number one scream for and Rio have
about four to five thousand years
nationally got 300 right so remember
it's not the number one movie it's the
number one per screen / screen yeah and
and that could change tomorrow or vibe
and it probably will but the most
important thing about that is that it
doesn't matter if I mean you could say
at 26 screens you do twenty thousand a
screen but what really matters is this
isn't 26 screens were out on bro 277
screens which is really really important
that's the distinction so yeah Matthew
Marsden your you get to play one of the
great villains in this piece he's a hero
clarify for us too you're not from
around here are you because some people
were saying that's a speech impediment I
respect
hey we run the way I for you go and you
might be able to buy it very cheaply
from what's it like you know what's I
mean you're your villain role is really
one of the most delicious pieces in it
and what do you do to it's a you know
what do you do to tap into that and have
fun with it without letting the fun show
too much well you know I think that he's
a complex character and I was very lucky
to have such a great script and kind of
great characters written by Iran which
was which was fantastic so all i had to
do is really try and be faithful to his
ideals as possible obviously for those
obviously of him everyone in this room
has probably read the book that I don't
look like James target the way is is
more of a physical embodiment of what he
believes in the in the book but i should
say i just watched john edwards okay
we're gonna work go on but that's the
trans you're good and we're gonna we're
going to come to your questions but i
want i watch
yeah really are just the actors but I
want to want to John clear up to rumors
that have been floating around the
interwebs before we turn it over to
questions from the audience of musical
job well I was going to ask first is it
true that Jar Jar Binks is going to be
written in charge on things no but tell
us about this this quote that flowed
around that part 3 will be a musical
look I mean all of you are on a
corporate board or you run a company or
you're involved and you say after your
folks hey put out some ideas no there's
no idea that's a bad idea we may not use
the idea and implement it but it's an
idea and so the thought came about that
I'm rands one of her favorite authors
was Victor you go and how can you
possibly make a musical from the serious
dark gray miserable Rainie lei mr. Avila
the title lame is ur habla musical get a
life ah well it just celebrated its 25th
anniversary is a fabulous serious
musical it wasn't you know the June is
busting out all over it's at its late
mr. habla but it had a place so it is an
idea and then some a friend of mine said
look the way to get out of this is say
it's marketing spin and you'll get out
of it get up but you know it will it be
amusing I'm not going to say her tonight
that it won't
but but I will say this seriously I
would like to see a differentiation a
continuation but a differentiation with
two and a differentiation with three I
think it will be a better it doesn't
mean we're going to not at that faithful
eat what Iran's ideas were remember
cinema is entertainment and you need to
and you need to keep that that fact in
mind so I don't know what the hell to
entry is going to be like tonight but we
want to strive for creativity and
promise all right well you guys are off
to a flying start let's turn it over to
the audience and Amy are you okay let's
I was very impressed by all the images
that we're that were showing the bridge
from above the train going fast etc how
much computer enhancing was involved and
how much was built in studio and just
pretending it was a huge place I'd like
you to respond to that question yeah we
shot all they're called plates and we
shot all of everything you saw with the
train was shot in plates and then the
train was digitally built into the shot
so it was a 50-50 deal so half of it was
done in plates and the other half was
done in what everybody understands now
CGI does that actually is done by a
company called Stargate a local company
we met with them John and I were very
impressed with the
the company he was very aware of the
book and had not had many opportunities
to work in motion pictures and you know
just like a lot of the people that came
on to help us with the picture I mean
they dug very very deep into their
creative talent we put a lot of faith in
what they did and a lot of pressure and
we're just really proud of what they did
and and Jonah deserve a lot of credit
yes you are exceeded arts potato
authoritative least eight that you're
not actually plants by Joe Biden and
Barack Obama and you're laying the
ground the cultural ground for a
high-speed rail revolution I'm just I
may have a nightmare about that yeah
well now you know who to blacks goodbye
get out that's good mark notion I have a
lot of chlorophyll okay more questions
for the panel question Oh
do you want to know what they're serving
in the club car on now is sticking on
the on the drink n flush wall in the
stage today I have another clip i live
in in Anna in a train town in train
country is a huge number retired train
workers in the little mountain town I
live in it and I've actually seen track
being replaced and so I was blown away
that the scene in the movie that showed
the laying of the track I've never seen
a depiction that was real I mean
whenever I've seen anything remotely
touching on that which isn't very often
it's been completely bogus so I mean was
there like a track Lane job that you
just went out and filmed or already know
it was that done for the movie no what
happened was we called hasbro in the
primary construction that builds those
machines and we asked them where the
machines were being used in the united
states and one was being used in in
bought in the boston area but they
recommended that we go to the Union
Pacific lines in Carlinville Illinois
and it was all luck we got there I was
telling Joan today that we got there I
was scheduled to start shooting that
sequence on Friday and so I got there on
Thursday figuring that I'd give me
plenty of time to prepare to shoot that
sequence well we saw the machines and
all the crews and all these guys and we
said I just ask these guys all my crew
hadn't even flown in from Los Angeles
one girls our production coordinator was
coming in from Hawaii and so we didn't
have our whole crew together and the guy
said to me we're finishing three weeks
this is our last day and so we stopped
it we went to the there was a Walmart
right there we bought ice packs to ice
down the cameras and we went immediately
to work and started shooting that
construction sequence and nut that
sequence went for almost two miles they
had machines and and guys and and things
you can you can't even fathom making a
movie there's so much bad luck so much
that that is unexpected unforeseen and
it and it happens yeah once in a while
you get lucky yeah and we got one Mike
was right there it took advantage of it
and we got authentic real it was real
what you saw was the real deal track
replacement yeah and it was stunning no
question back so obviously obviously a
lot of Rands work involves long
monologues stats are very difficult to
incorporate into a film medium I'm
wondering how you're planning to
incorporate especially in the later
parts of the works to have longer
monologues work that message into the
movie and if you're not going to
actually have five minute long
monologues in there if you're going to
have the actors do things for you to use
outside of the actual film like you've
been doing with the voice mails from
various characters and things like that
and by the way if you haven't go to the
Atlas Shrugged part 1 web
and check out the voice messages I mean
note that was brilliant they have
berries characters leaving you know
telephone answering machine messages
which are really clever and insightful
and a hell of a lot of fun but how do
you let me get a plug in there for Scott
desappio who Harmon brought on which has
he has utilized online technologies
unbelievably like these things you're
just referring to and we have really
gotten an awful lot of marketing is not
the right word but on but awareness and
it just hits millions of hits with the
trailer and on and on we we've really
gotten the word out and Scott's a feeler
what do you what do you do about the
radio address or you know and then the
money speech and other things yeah what
what's coming down the pike what was
coming well the money speech is about
six pages we've got to get it under a
page and yet that's a lot I'm in a page
of the book and that's like three pages
maybe of and that is very tough but
there's so much good stuff and so you
know you know the one hand you've got
real filmmakers and then you've got you
know you know you've got an Objectivist
you want someone who wants to say what I
engrams message is but you've got to be
have enough discipline to say no on one
side and no one the other on the one
side they want six pages of this money
speech which is brilliant I mean where
he says that you know producers are
trying to produce and they need to get
permission from those who produce
nothing and maybe a brilliant sentences
in there and these guys are going to
take it down to you know 45 words and
next cut move on and that's but that's
moviemaking and then on the other hand
you got Gary Cooper ayan ran got her way
with Fountainhead and what I will not I
self my self-interest will be forever in
the way and he can't do that
you know it's a movie so so so one of
the things we're doing is we're not
doing stuff like a left-wing right-wing
conservative progressive Democrat
Republican we none of that stuff it's
about ideas anyway and so we need to get
six great pages of the money speech and
other things not anymore to think about
the gold speech and 60 pages I just had
dinner give me a break you haven't seen
yet yes going to sing in front okay and
so no but but so how do you get that
down to one page what we're going to do
it and there's some ideas again this is
like the musical but I mean the idea is
perhaps perhaps it is a Riordan that is
Tigers wedding so it might be in a
casino and it might be that he's walking
about maybe a chip voles and ladies a
zoo yeah money is a root of all evil and
he says she was me madam and he's so
you're gonna have to have bodily
movement that's the first thing that
comes to mind you can't just stand there
and say no money is the root of all her
of all good and the virtue of money is
we're not not going to do that so it has
to be where there's movement and maybe
someone else will say a few of the
things you know it'll be a participative
turns Tucker
I you know yeah I think he's going to
audition for gold next hey yeah why is
one of diamond few things first up yeah
I want to recognize up Matt kibbe and
FreedomWorks but also Alexander and
students for liberty have wearing out
and he's another big partner and friend
also you don't want to recognize that
Brian O'Toole as a person is working
right now on breaking down you know the
second part of the book it's not an easy
task is a credibly hard-working guy you
saw him on the screen there green and
kelly and so so they'll figure it out
but ultimately it's a collaborative
effort and I think as John said really
the key is to create banter that gets
across the message yep there you my
question is about the politics of
Hollywood and how you ended up
interacting with that in terms of the
actors all the different many suppliers
and companies did you have problems with
getting people to you know actively work
on the film because of the generally
left-wing politics of Hollywood well
look yeah you aren't on to me into that
person you're on film by the way so I am
careful what you say hi mom you belong
to a union be careful the quick answer
the quick answer is no with no problems
none whatsoever from on the broad
strokes of all the post and all the
second unit and all this all the big
shots you saw none zero no politics game
alright so I don't know where you were
but when we were
but we were casting for example we were
cast in the movie I mean we got almost
no support from the major talent
agencies I mean you're a casting agency
you are and you've got a slate of 68
great actors and actresses you got a
reputation and some who the Atlas what
and MC you're not going to have your
clients go and then and then there's
been the production falls apart and you
know i'm not going to go i'm going to go
to her right now so a lot of reputation
was at stake by these and we're going
you know you can talk about it because
you were there during the casting
process and you know you know sort of
the level of courage and the risk that
each one of you took to walk in and
audition with Ronnie ethical I mean you
can tell people well you know I'm an
actress to let me talk about me I think
that for me was really easy because I
recognize the importance of the message
of the movie and I think it was vitally
important that the movie get made and I
was just very very honored to even be
considered to have a part in it
unfortunately that's not the case with
everyone out there and and certainly you
would get many people who would say you
know what you don't do that because it's
going to damage your career and if
anyone thinks that that's not true that
it is true you absolutely stay worried
about a beam in a way you're in a
position where it's your movie is a big
hit 200 a lot because that's what I'm
going to be doing tomorrow no but the
other thing I want to say is and I don't
think people really appreciate this the
difficulty in in working with actors on
the whole just want to go back to the
other question because actors we're a
nightmare we always want to go and run
with our emotions and do things with the
material and be creative which is a
wonderful thing but also with something
like this is very difficult because you
don't stray too much from the message
and these guys were on set every single
day making sure that you guys got the
movie that you
saw and and its really is a testament to
them because it was exhausting for the I
Solomon on a daily basis and it really
was a difficult process and John and
Harmon and they all these guys they
played down but it's a very very
difficult process to get the movie that
you saw and so it was a six-week shoot
which is somewhat short for an hour and
for you very good and I would dare say
there's not five me and not five
directors that had the energy and the
persistence that Paul Johansson had I
mean it was like eight in the morning
you know go to Hollywood caters get your
eggs and you know we're going to shoot
at nine and go to 12 in the morning and
then get up at you know seven maybe an
hour earlier go ahead and do that maybe
a break at three hours in the afternoon
you know then it's a weekend but we got
to do one of those days and I mean it
was an exhausting high-energy exercise
to get this film made in terms of just
the day-to-day shoot of six weeks hey
are you out there we've got a question
right here okay I just wanted to say
that in the 70s I was in Boston at the
ford hall forum and i asked an R and
what actress she had in mind for Dagny
and she said katherine hepburn the way
she played in philadelphia story but i
think that you chose an excellent
actress and be a little hard for her
Katharine Hepburn's do it now
the hair color doesn't matter Thank and
another question right over here what
was the running time of part one the
entire that the film is about a hundred
minutes okay all right and and how much
film did you shoot to do part 1 it must
have been a lot well you know it's
what's interesting is when we started
out I mean we had a we had choices about
how we would film the movie in what
technology we would use and you know
John it wanted to use the best most
cutting-edge technology because with
that seemed sort of consistent with the
spirit of the book so we use the what
they call the red camera which is a very
high resolution camera with new
technology we had a couple of little
hiccups with it I don't know how much we
use but it is many many many hours of
footage and many many takes to get what
you saw I mean the actors were literally
cast when I think we called them on
thursday and we started that sunday okay
so there they didn't have an opportunity
to rehearse or sit down at a table and
read or get the sort of direction that
they wanted or fit it into the costumes
or any of those things so it was a very
you know expedited process so during the
course of filming I mean we went through
it took a long time to capture what you
saw and I would say I mean what and
takes node and then nobody ten takes of
this way and then then take to the other
and what would average take slowly
average take some change you're with me
only one
yeah I know you read the book before I
started filming yeah I know for example
grant bowler was filming two movies at
the same time he came up with filmed in
Australia and came flu yeah in the 29th
he worked two days someone came back
over the day line and worked for us and
the other movie was the Che Guevara
follow-up that's a good one and how long
was post-production how many well
post-production for us the film was
completed on februari 18th and post
production starts immediately but it's a
very dynamic process because you're
really discovering what you have the
director gets an opportunity without
interference from John or me and then
based on you know our assessment of what
that looks like you know what is our
next step and so I think that was in
mid-june mid-september or let's say
October over on it yet so October then
John and I had then our opportunity we
brought Mike in to help you know express
the story that we we think you know it
should have been across the app process
took us through the the 18th the music
for example we didn't start that until
January that was a month a second unit
director Mike had a lot of stuff out
there so you so I your question directly
is no film was shot on this picture none
it was all done digitally with the red
mystery it's called the red camera with
mysterium chip and about fifty percent
of all movies in Hollywood now are being
shot that way and probably seventy five
percent of television is shot the new
era flex
digital cameras are coming in it's only
a matter of time before there are no
more movie shot and film thank you a
correction to what Diana said she says
it was not Philadelphia Story was
Katherine Hepburn in bill of divorcement
right we've one more question over here
I know it's a lot of decisions were made
to make make the film work but I
realized that this afternoon that I had
not heard what i called the concerto of
deliverance and I wondered if the reason
it had been not put in was that you
couldn't find or afford a composer that
might actually be able to write such a
wonderful tune no no you want to answer
that one yeah I'm sorry I didn't get the
gist of the question well the film
concertos playing would that we just
didn't even include that see in a movie
so I didn't it didn't really fit in it
wasn't for the reason you described it
just wasn't part of the screenplay so it
was just a creative decision at the
outside tonight I'll answer that too
what are the things one of the things in
a movie like this and I've adapted a few
movies is it really really there's a lot
of it you can it's a lot of what isn't
in there becomes a focus point so you
look at that that's one of the things
that isn't there the salient points of
the story are there so you look at
everything and there's a lot of things
that aren't there and that's one of the
things that really that was just sort of
a creative decision that I mean we
really SAT and we thought it over and we
thought is that more important than
Dagny dealing straight away with the
room yeah at the beginning of the
picture the Eddie Willers and the and
and the Taggart scene does that is more
important than whether the concerto she
hears that concerto that's what you're
talking about right yeah yeah we have
time for one last question right over
here I have so many compliments I'm
winnegan begin I love the sound I could
understand all of the dialogue which is
very unusual in today's film I have a
question and you may not have an answer
yet but it's accompanied by a great wish
but at some point you will Dilys a
director's cut with some of the scenes
that those of us who wish that it could
have been longer and you could have
filmed more will be included what the
irony for this film is that the cut you
saw is longer actually then the
director's cut yeah we actually went
when John and I intent and Mike you
looked at what had been delivered to us
we felt that there was ways to open the
film up and we thought that that was
important to do there was a lot of
things that we added in there so I hate
to tell you what you see pretty much is
is what's there I don't think we have
left out in any scenes mean as we set up
here you know one of the conversations
that John and I you know have our other
scenes that we wish we could have filmed
to put in there there's a lot of just as
you mentioned there's a lot of really
great meaningful moments in the book
that just from the pure practical nature
and that at some point we needed to stop
pre-production of the movie which that
stopped three days before we ended
filming so we were constantly looking at
what we could get in with the resources
we had so in the scramble of making the
film that's that's it and then we did
expand it out with what three weeks more
of shooting afterwards to create a lot
of the
the beauty that you see and I think the
the liberties that we really took were
as usual in the beginning of the movie
the CNBC stuff to give people a real in
the moment what's happening now you know
what are we concerned about the budget
deficit it's crazy the debt and a whole
bit and where we are the mo the market
in 2009 and I think March at the bottom
6600 so you know we needed to to give
you immediately take people in and then
and then at the end we needed to be sure
that we adapted faithfully to the book
but not just you know here's the sign
take it and leave it I I'm leading a
delay how did he and emotionalism and
one break person I don't know if they're
here but I have to say it because
they're there they picked it up and
there was a little bit of borrowing in
terms of going with the win and Tara
because that emotionalism was brought
out and I don't have any violent i don't
need to say i'm not going to hide at her
cover we really did want to gain get
some emotionalism out of it so having
having Dagny and but it's in the blue
that scream lion ran said in there it
was a scream she never knew that she had
with inner or something like that so you
have that scream then you've got the
music coming in golf theme and the waste
of it all they're just about to start
the second Renaissance and then
thank you can you tell us I'd like to
ask one last question take the
prerogative here the movies going great
what can we expect looking forward but
what is what what is your vision what is
your dream or where we go from here but
I'm gonna let him answer the question I
just want to get a few to two important
things one is yeah I want to recognize
June John's wife very instrumental
because she really kicked gel and
barbacoa I'm thinking when we started
production send gone out to to Hollywood
and said you know go make this and I
really think that was the kick in the
pants he needed and really has been a
you know a big part the other thing is
what what really needs to happen for us
and then John can answer the question is
in order for this film to succeed now I
mean we got enormous support from reason
and in getting the word out now we need
word of mouth we need people to go tell
other people about the movie that is the
best strongest most persuasive form of
marketing so if if the movie inspired or
moved you or you believe somebody should
see it now is not the time to be shy now
is the time to tell them to go see it or
the theaters will move us out for
something else if people go and see the
movie it will stay in the theaters and
we can really inspire and reach a very
very large already ready to okay good
ready know it cut so when we were 21
yeah so to answer David's question so
the aspiration is that April 15 2012 we
will bring out part two and part three
April 15 2013